- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is define
happiness for yourself.
Over to you, Alfred Hitchcock.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Mr. Hitchcock, what is
your definition of happiness?
- A clear horizon,
nothing to worry about on your plate
only things that are
creative and not destructive,
and that's within yourself.
Within me,
I can't bear quarreling.
I can't bear feelings between people.
I think hatred is wasted energy
and it's all non-productive.
I'm very sensitive.
A sharp word said by, say,
a person who has a temper
if they're close to me,
hurts me for days.
I know we're only human,
we do go in for these various emotions,
call them negative emotions,
but when all these are removed
and you can look forward
and the road is clear ahead
and now you're going to create something,
I think that's as happy as
I would ever want to be.
- I think this is one of
the most important exercises
that you can do, not
just as an entrepreneur,
but as a human being.
To understand what
happiness looks like for you
so that you can build
a life and a business
that makes you happier.
Self- awareness is important.
It's why I wrote the book, Your One Word.
To understand what is the thing
that makes you come alive.
Understanding that,
understanding what you're one
main core value is that you love
and then being proactive
and going after that.
In the book, we go through that exercise
of thinking about everything
that has made you come alive in the past.
What makes you happy?
Make a list of all the
things that make you happy.
The movies you watch and
the people in your life
and what you loved about your parents
and whoever your favorite teacher was.
Of the hundreds of teachers that you had,
the one or two people that stood out,
what was it about them?
What were the highest highs in your life?
What were you doing?
What are the activities
that make you come alive?
To build a happy life,
you want to be around that
as much as possible.
You want to be doing things
that make you come alive, right?
Who wants a life that is boring?
That you're doing stuff
that is just repetitive
and beneath you consistently.
Nobody wants that life.
But doing the things that
create the spark for you,
that add tons of value
to other people's lives,
that give you that proud feeling
of the work that you're
doing is contributing,
that's what you want to get to.
Making that list of the things
that make you come alive
and finding what's the
common theme between
all of those things.
For me, it's belief.
I've talked about my
favorite movie is Seabiscuit.
It's about this undersized
horse and oversized jockey,
an owner that had no money,
that everybody was counting out
and somehow those three guys came together
and they won a ton of races.
They beat all the odds, that
underdog story of believe.
My parents told me I was
a Gastrilli Carmichael,
I could do anything I wanted, is believe.
My favorite teachers were about believe.
The people that I want
to surround myself with
need to be about believe.
Why it's so important
is 'cause understanding
what value is so important
to me, and was in the past,
now let's me build a future that's better.
So, I can build a business around believe.
I can bring teammates on
board who believe in believe.
I can be more proactive.
Instead of having life
happen to me by accident
or instead of, even worse,
having other people's projections
of what I should do, impact me.
If you don't know what you stand for
you will fall for anything.
You'll just be walking around living
up to other people's expectations
instead of doing the
thing that you want to do.
But, a lot of people
don't have the clarity.
A lot of people walk
through life feeling like
they could be doing way more.
You know that you could be doing way more
in your life than you're
currently doing right now
but you don't know what to do
because you're not clear
on what your value is.
You're not clear on what you stand for
so you can't build that ideal life.
In my view, I'm biased,
I wrote a book about it,
but in my view it's one of the single
most important exercises
that you can ever do
in your life, whether you're
an entrepreneur or not.
To understand what it
is that makes you happy.
What you're most important
core value is for you
has always been, always will be,
and with design, with
intent, with purpose,
building a life and a business around it
that will make you happy forever.
Imagine that, it's possible.
It's achievable
and I want it for you.
So, the question of the day today is
how do you define happiness for yourself?
What is your one word?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to Regina Ross from
ReginasBeautyBoutique.com.
Thank you so much, Regina,
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
It really, really, really,
really means a lot to me.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going